hello guys and welcome to another video
in this video we have a scene
description from secret invasion which
is an upcoming marvel tv show releasing
on disney plus so if you want to avoid
spoilers and click off this video now
with that out of the way let's get into
the scene descriptions so the first
description was while shooting emilia
clarke's character she walks down a
flight of stairs and stops to look into
a bag she's carrying with concern maria
hill tails her emilia clark continues
walking in the streets with maria hill
following her so this leaked description
comes from the leaked images you have
been seeing on screen here you can see
maria hill has a bleeding nose in this
scene so she's possibly engaged in some
action of some kind but apart from that
we don't know too much else about this
scene so moving on to the next scene we
have some images of emilia clarke
reacting to a bombing that has taken
place there's also a video of the scene
where we see emilia clarke and kensley
benedict they seem to be working
together as their characters leave the
aftermath of the explosion and hurt
citizens at the event so judging by this
information i would say emilia clarke's
character is a villain as she is seen
leaving the aftermath of an explosion
which i would say she's had a pardon
apart from that we don't know anything
else about amelia clark's character um
the show doesn't have too much
information or leaks regarding it which
i think is a good thing but i think it's
cool to see maria hill back in action
i'm actually really excited to see what
amelia clark's character will be because
i'm a big fan of her performances anyway
with that out of the way that's pretty
much everything for this video so let me
know in the comment section below what
type of character do you think emilia
clarke will play and if you haven't
already guys please like and subscribe
and turn notifications on to show your
support thanks for watching